hey guys it's benefits of a G from G
tracker here and today's video isn't
really be much about how to flip in
general but rather to talk about the
different types of merchants out there
in game and I've categorized it into
three groups um but obviously anyone of
these groups can uh mingle between any
of the different categories out there um
but the three groups that I've
categorized would be your beginner type
Merchants your average merchants and
your masterminds out there um and again
this isn't meant to categorize anyone
specifically into a category obviously
you can share some traits between a
beginner to Mastermind and anything in
between uh but this is rather to help
you guys visualize and um understand how
to how other Merchants are thinking game
and how you could possibly Advance
yourself on trying to give yourself more
of an edge um continuously over time to
better yourself as a merchant in the
long run so first off the list we have
our beginner type Merchants out there
and these guys generally have little to
no experience whatsoever flipping they
may have watched some YouTube videos out
there and they're going to try and
replicate the items that the merchants
have tried flipping in their videos but
generally these guys have little to no
experience and they're going to have no
clue whatsoever on where to start and
what items to flip so the most common
phrases you you hear these guys say
would be what items are good to flip
right now this is [__] nothing is
buying or selling I don't flip anymore I
can't make any money and my all-time
favorite what the [__] is
that U that that's something that you'll
probably hear from time to time when
you're walking around with some kind of
cosmetic item and they'll probably come
up to you and ask you what item that is
these guys generally don't have any clue
whatsoever on what to do in game in
terms of flipping uh they might ask
around on what to flip they're not
really experimenting themselves and
trying to get you know their own
experience on what is working for them
and what they would be comfortable
flipping in terms of how much they
should invest and what they would be
comfortable losing in the long run and
the most common traits that these guys
have would be that they're either brand
new to the game or they're brand new to
flipping as a whole uh this is going to
go hand inand with how unaware they are
of how volatile the market can be
so if they try making an offer in one
day and it's and it starts tanking the
next day this might discourage them a
little bit so they are going to have the
highest rate of quitting this type of uh
money-making in game so it does kind of
play a little bit of psychology here if
someone was brand new to flipping and
they've watched some YouTube videos and
they tried their hand at it in game and
they had some success and they made some
money off of it then that's going to be
kind of like a little bit of an
incentive for them to continue flipping
as they had some success on day one and
if they do face any losses in the future
then they can go back to their first day
thinking that you know they did make a
profit off of this at one point in time
and maybe they're making a mistake at
that current point in time when they did
lose
money whereas if someone were to flip at
the very beginning um after they watched
some YouTube videos to get them give
themselves a foundation and they lost
money immediately or they didn't make as
much money as they had hoped then that's
going to be kind of like a deterrent
from them from flipping as a whole and
they may not flip ever
again um but those who do stay these
guys are 100% not paying attention to
the updates or the uh twitch stream q&as
that's not to say that they're not
watching the q&as or reading the updates
uh they certainly can participate in
that but they're probably not giving giv
a second thought in terms of how that's
going to affect the market ingame
they're probably just going to go about
their ways um you know just kind of
doing whatever they're doing previously
ingame and not really take any notice of
that and of course if a beginner were to
use a tool like G tracker then they're
probably not doing any kind of thought
process as
to what the information is showing them
in terms of like where the price really
really is valued at in the long run
whether or not a mass hype is inflating
the price or a mass panic is devaluing
the price of an item they're not really
thinking too much in terms of where the
item should be really valued at and
they're taking the information that
they're shown at face value without
digging a little bit and I'm sorry guys
if this puts some of you guys into this
category but hopefully that lights a
little bit of fire underneath you guys
to try and get you guys out of this
little box that you guys are putting
yourselves in which is definitely set up
setting yourselves up to
fail uh because you're not you're not
digging into um you're not digging in at
all in terms of where these items should
really be at so if you're looking at the
current price offer price sell price and
approximate profit and you're only
basing it off of that then you're you're
only setting yourself up to lose money
in the long run it's not not a win-win
situation um you're basically trying to
have the information fed to you on a
silver platter and just kind of go in
game with little to no effort and try
and make a profit which of course it
could happen you could certainly make
some money by doing this but in the long
run you are 100% going to lose money
just solely doing this um I have a
little graph here showing um if someone
someone were to you know make an
investment and they did make a profit in
the beginning but then in the long run
it's just going to kind of go down and
eventually they're just going to lose
money so if if you're in this category
guys if some of you guys are doing this
please stop please stop please actually
you know click on the item and you know
take more information in and see where
the item really stands you know is the
item skyrocketing is it hitting its cap
from its current history is it hitting
its current bottom or is it you know
kind of continuously going on a decline
um a good example of a an item that's
declining would be the armadil godsword
which has been declining for a very long
long time now um so if you're in this
box please stop please do some more
research and not base all of your flips
solely on this little bit of information
that is literally just a snapshot of the
past few minutes do some research so you
don't make those mistakes
and then you have your average type
Merchants out there who have made
anywhere from 1 million to 500 million
GP and that's on Old School not RS3
that's a completely different Market uh
but as you can see here in the
screenshot I posted some of the more
commonly flipped items by this category
so you have your pvm and PVP gear and
maybe a few cosmetic items so if you
were to watch any YouTube flipping video
video out there these are generally the
type of type of items that these guys
are going to be flipping uh that's not
to say that's a bad thing I would say
99% of the player base of all Merchants
out there fit into this category so it
does make sense that these videos would
flip these types of items uh but these
are generally this is generally the
category of items that these guys would
flip and these guys are generally more
comfortable with losing money they're
generally going to be more prone to
accepting losses and getting back on
their feet and continuing on they may do
a little bit of research maybe a bit a
little bit of planning um so they're
kind of moving away from that beginner
stage where they have no clue of what
they're doing and they're trying to you
know experiment with the market and try
and learn as much as they can and your
average Merchant out there may or may
not start paying attention to the twitch
streams or the update that have been
implemented in game and what I mean by
that
is by trying to see and figure out how
these updates or the twitch streams will
impact the market in the long run and I
would say about this is kind of like
50/50 on whether or not this category
you know tries to pay attention to that
um but like I talked about in the
previous screenshot their flips are
pretty predictable um they're going to
be flipping the more common type items
just like everybody El else and they may
or may not use tools like G tracker but
like I talked about in the beginner
category just because you're using a
tool like GE tracker doesn't mean that
it's just going to be your gold ticket
to the profit Zone you're always going
to have to do some research on your own
so those of you guys that are in this
category always do research always look
at as much information as you possibly
can which definitely includes the price
graphs their his
and of course paying attention to
updates and twitch
streams and like I said earlier these
guys are generally more comfortable with
losing money and if they do lose money
then they're going to probably continue
flipping without any
hesitation now the biggest downside to
the average Merchant out there is that
they're part of the mass herd so what I
mean by that is they'll
generally they're they're basically
generally jumping on the bandwagon when
an item begins to show that it is going
to rise significantly or they Panic sell
when an item starts declining pretty
quickly and they're not going to try and
make those long-term predictions um
based off of the information that is
available to
them so um if an atom starts Rising
they'll probably try and jump on that as
it's rising and try and make a little
bit of a profit as opposed to trying to
make the prediction before it happens so
if you are part of the master heard part
of the average Merchant out there you
can't always predict the items
increasing in price it's it's impossible
it's not always going to happen but you
should try and learn as much as you can
about updates what the mods have to say
and try and make those predictions
yourself and your average Merchants out
there are going to be more inclined to
look at the information and dig a little
bit deeper like I talked about earlier
so if they were using a site like G
tracker then they're more than likely
going to start looking at the pricing
graphs and trying to determine whether
or not based on the fluctuations shown
on the screenshot here if they could
make a profit off of that item um as you
can clearly see in the screenshot though
at that current point in time the item
was hitting a new low so someone who was
comfortable with doing a little bit of
research they might try and look at a
longer time frame to determine whether
or not this item has hit his cap and is
going to go on a decline rather soon
which is kind of going on a decline
right now or whether or not this is a
new low and whether or not that's going
to increase based off whether or not
there is an update in game or an update
that is planned that would make this
item continuously decline or the absence
of an update which would mean that this
item may possibly increase again in the
future so the average players out there
are the average merchants who are on the
higher end of this category would
certainly look at this type of
information and try and make those
predictions and this could certainly
play off in any time frame they could
certainly try and make an investment
during the day and flip it within a
couple of hours or try and flip it in a
span of a week it really all DET
determines on whether or not what you
are most comfortable
with and then I've included a little um
profit graph here at on the bottom
and I've included this for you know a
very specific reason and that this user
is very comfortable with making decent
sized amounts of profits um with little
chunks here and there but as you can
clearly tell within a span of a few
months they're almost nearing at 60
million total profit so this would be
someone who is definitely on the higher
end of the average merchanting skill and
of course uh no one starts out with 2
billion or 600 million so this could
easily be someone who would fit in The
Mastermind category and they are just
starting out um but this is certainly a
graph in which you guys want to aim for
so and finally we have our masterminds
and these are generally players who have
made 600 million to more than 2 billion
and of course obviously if someone were
to start out and they share some of
these traits and they've only made 10
million then obviously they's still a
mastermind and and someone who has made
600 million to 2 billion but don't share
some of these traits could obviously be
an average Merchant these are just some
of the traits that these guys generally
hold overall and I have a little
screenshot here of basically some of the
more comfortable flips that they would
invest in which would include Spirit
Shields third age uh items brand new
items that are released into the games
like Dragon claw um abys of bludgeon and
the dragon Warhammer so these guys are
generally much more with risk and are
much better at diversifying their
Investments and on to the more common
traits that these guys hold would be
that they are very likely to hold more
than one flipping account I would say
99% of these guys have more than one
merching account and um for obvious
reasons and they are definitely
long-term planners and are exceptionally
patient they are marvelous at
diversifying their Investments and they
pay excessive attention to q&as so what
I mean by paying attention to Q&A I mean
these guys are literally noting down
anything that they find useful and
they'll hold on to that for a very long
time and they'll definitely keep a
record of information they find useful
so basically anything else in game maybe
something that was talked about on
Reddit uh these guys will keep note of
virtually everything and not always but
they can be Market manipulators which
has of course given Merchants a bad name
and and these guys are definitely the
the players that could influence the
markets in a negative fashion and I do
have one example of an item that was
manipulated um I believe about a year
ago but it wasn't manipulated in a sense
that it affected the entire Community it
was really just a small group of people
who actually could afford this item and
like I said earlier Guys these guys will
definitely pay attention to q&as and no
matter how long it's been they will keep
note and tabs of every single Q&A that
they find useful including time periods
within that video itself and they may
may or may not make investments based on
those q&as and if they don't see an item
becoming valuable over time in which
they would hope to flip the item back
they may try and social
engineer by making Reddit post on
2007scape by trying to convince the mods
and the community that these items need
a buff and that the mods said so in a
previous stream um usually trying to use
the mods thems who have also referenced
this as something that needs a buff
generally giv gives the community um a
further incentive to further support
that post which could potentially create
a little hype of that item artificially
inflating it in which that Merchant
would have made some money off that just
by having the community back him up um
him or her
so these guys are definitely long-term
planners and just like Market
manipulation they can also um include
some social engineering which of course
includes trying to post on 2007 scape
Reddit and I have a little I have a
little screenshot here for you guys um
which kind of gives you an idea of the
type of merchants there are in game I
mean the The Mastermind percent out of
the three categories I would say take up
less than 1% of all merchants and the
these guys are extremely wealthy and as
as a fun little hobby for them they
could of course have a massive
collection of variet of items in which
it's simply just fun for them and they
have no intention whatsoever of selling
these off um this does kind of give you
an idea of items of what it would look
like if they were to try and make an
investment on an item in the long run
and hope that these items kind of
Skyrocket in the future in which of
course um if you guys know just by a
little logic If an item were to suddenly
increase in price these guys would
certainly dump their items off and
depending on Pon of how much of a demand
there is they may or may not um kind of
level that price off to a more medium
price or just kind of create kind of
like crash the price altogether so if an
item skyrockets um and they kind of dump
these items off and there's really no
demand for it then the item is just
going to kind of plummet again to its
original price and then some of these
items are just kind of like fun
collections like the lava ruins Bando
page and the bronze items um of course I
don't assume that these guys are trying
to make any money off of this this is
something just kind of like a fun
collection but it does give you a clear
picture of the type of merchants you
guys are up against in game and what you
guys should hope to be your goal in the
future um maybe you shouldn't have like
um maybe you shouldn't be making
collections as a an investment type
portion but you you know of course you
could have a fun collection like these
guys but of course again this is what it
would look like if someone were to try
and make money off of their
collection and finally guys I wanted to
show you some real life examples of what
their flips would look like and
obviously if you guys are looking at the
price these are 100% not their current
price anymore um but of course they
could reach that price anytime in the
future but at the time of this video
these prices are um much lower or much
higher than they are in the video as
opposed to what they are currently in
game so if you look at the far right you
have someone who has been flipping
Elijah and spirit shields on a
consistent basis and making a lot of
money um several million um maybe on
every single flip and doing that on a
consistent basis and then I said I was
going to provide a an example of a
market manipulation uh but I wouldn't
I'm not sure if this is a manipulation
per se this is rather just kind of like
a market control and I'm sure many of
you guys have heard of Wilson he is by
far the most famous Merchant out there
in terms of RuneScape um I mean this guy
this guy is really known for his crazy
Investments and he became even more
famous on old school with his domination
of third age items uh when they came out
so one point in time he started to um he
had an idea of trying to control all
third age long swords so as you can see
in the picture on the far left um he
started buying and buying third age long
swords until he had all of them well I
wouldn't say all of them obviously some
people in game had them but as you can
tell he got it to a point where it was
hitting Max cash stack and he continued
buying them in the GE over and over
again so anytime they came in he made
sure he had them and it reached a point
where if anyone wanted a third age long
sword they'd have to go to him in game
off the GE and pay a much higher price
than it was um than it was a Max cash
deck so at one point in time I think he
was selling them for over three billion
so as you can tell if you if he was
buying them at 2 billion and flipping
them for 3 billion that's a massive
profit that that's huge um that's just
that's that's literally giving you guys
a real picture of the type of merchants
these guys are and what they're truly
capable of and what you should really
hope for your goal to be in the future
and obviously um third age long swords
and Elijah and spirit Shields are not at
this price anymore so these are kind of
like safe items I felt was showing in
terms of this kind of stuff but you know
that's going to be the end of the video
guys if you guys enjoyed this video be
sure to leave a like down below um be
sure to comment down below as well in
terms of what kind of videos you guys
want to see in the future and be sure to
subscribe to show your support and till
next time till next time guys and good
luck merching